so some of you may know this this is
completely legit I love magic I really
do huge huge fan and I recently went to
the wonderful Magic Castle here in LA
yes some lovely magic castle and this is
true I was so amazed by this next
performer that I had to have him on the
show that's how good he is please
welcome the amazing Carl coppertop
everybody called you mind if I tell them
what happened
so I'm sitting at the bar okay tease a
few drinks in more than a few which made
it even better a lot easier for me as
for sure I hope some of them are drunk
so you guys have been drinking right
yeah at one point I wanted to yell you
had 5 ones we you got some ones from
everybody and and then you can you do
this trick there's the trick that I want
to see I don't have any money I'm glad
you have some money well I'll give you
one of my dollars you can check it out
this is about the closest thing the real
magic could ever see cuz if you had real
magic powers you wouldn't be like
finding cards and yeah that's right
unless you're hungry then rabbit out of
a hat
medieval ages that may be all right put
in the studio so if you had five dollars
one two three four five you get the
backstage pass they get the front here
yeah I know so on the faces on the backs
nothing else now I want you to watch
this quote because a lot of times you
know people think magicians use their
sleeves P so grab my wrist yeah nothing
goes up nothing that's going in just
don't steal my watch alright if I did
that would be so badass I invited you
here we go you ready one two three
one two three four five hundred ah
that's what I'm talking about that's why
I don't have a real job now imagine if
you were liquored up in a castle well
you know the thing is though we're on
television now so the NSA progress has
been some kind of watchlist you know yes
sir one to the hundreds yeah so I have
to turn the bathroom okay so here we go
make sure it's a real hundred first of
all hold it to the light you can see the
the real holiday no one ever does good
magic makes me want to lunge it you
especially have $500 in my hands yes
right
alright so 500 hours watch this potion
can you get the backstage one two three
four five we're trying to right back in
the $1 bills are you watching I'm
watching and they're watching
everybody's watching yeah once is good
but you know let's go let's go the
opposite let's go for a thousand how
about